what I hope to do in this video is get a
little bit more practice thinking about
absolute value of the difference of
numbers as the distance between those
two numbers so in this first question we
are asked which of the following
expressions are equivalent to the
absolute value of a minus B and this is
a reminder the absolute value of a minus
B this this expression this is going to
give us the distance between a and B so
it's going to give us this distance
right over here it's going to give us
this distance right over here that is
the absolute value of a minus B which is
of course the same thing as the absolute
value of B minus a so which of these
expressions are equivalent so this first
one has the absolute value of a minus
the absolute value of B well what is the
absolute value of a well that's the
distance that a is from zero so that's
going to be this distance this distance
right over here is the absolute value of
a that's the absolute value of a right
over there and then the absolute value
of B is going to be this distance that's
the distance that B is from zero so that
right over there is going to be the
absolute value of B that's the absolute
value of B so if you take if you say the
absolute value of a minus the absolute
value of B what are you going to be left
with well you're going to be left with
you're going to be left with this
distance you're going to be left with
this distance right over here this
distance is the absolute value of a
minus the absolute value of B absolute
value of a minus this distance is going
to give you this Green distance well
that's exactly what we have up here the
absolute value of a minus B is the
distance between a and B and that's what
this green distance is as well so this
is going to be equivalent to the
absolute value of a minus B and if you
want to really verify it you could try
it with some numbers I mean what they
tell us about a and B is that both of
them are going to be negative they're
both to the left of zero and we also see
that B is greater than a or it's less
negative than a so you can even try it
with some numbers you could say well
maybe B is negative one and a is
negative five and then verify that this
would be true now what about the
absolute value of a
plus the absolute value of B well that
would be taking this distance this
magenta distance absolute value of a and
then adding it to this blue distance
that absolute value of B so this would
give you a larger distance then the then
the distance between those two points or
you could try it with numbers I mean
imagine a world just like I said imagine
a world where a is equal to negative
five and B is equal to negative one well
in this world the distance between the
two the absolute value of a minus B
would be equal to the absolute value of
negative five negative 5 minus negative
1 minus negative 1 which is the same
thing as the absolute value of negative
5 plus 1 which is equal to the absolute
value of negative 4 which is equal to 4
so for these particular numbers and I
just picked them I just pick two
negative numbers where a is more
negative than B the way it's drawn this
distance in green or this distance right
over here would be 4 now the absolute
value of a absolute value of a plus the
absolute value of B in this circumstance
is going to be equal to 5 it's going to
be the absolute value of negative 5
which just be 5 plus the absolute value
of negative 1 which would be 1 this
would be equal to 6 so for these numbers
once again I just pick two random
numbers that met the constraints that
both are negative and that a is more
negative than B is it didn't hold up so
this is not going to be the case and I'm
not going to select none of the above
because I found a choice that I know is
going to be true let's go to another one
of these
let's do several more of these which of
the following expressions are equivalent
to the absolute value of a minus B once
again absolute value of a minus B that
is the distance between a and B that is
this distance that I'm drawing right now
that is this distance right over here
that is the absolute value of a minus B
well what is this first choice just a
minus B without the absolute value well
we see that a is less than B it's more
to the left in fact a is negative and B
is positive so if you take a negative
number and then you subtract a positive
number for
but you're going to get a negative
number this thing right over here is
going to be negative or if you subtract
a larger number from a smaller number
but you're going to get a negative value
but the distance between these two
numbers we took the absolute value this
is a positive value this is just a
distance so this isn't going to be the
case now let's look at this choice the
negative of B minus a well B minus a is
going to be positive how do we know that
well B is larger than a B is greater
than a so if B is greater than a B minus
a is going to be positive but then we're
taking the negative of it so this whole
expression is going to be negative is
going to be negative again another way
to think about it B is a positive number
you subtract a negative number from it
that's the same thing as adding the
absolute value of that negative number
this part is going to be positive then
you have this negative out front of it
it is going to be negative and like the
last example you could try out numbers
that meet these constraints maybe B is
positive three and a is negative two and
encourage you to try this out figure out
what the absolute value of a minus B is
it'll be five and figure out which of
these give you that same result and
neither of them will so the answer here
is none of the above
let's keep going there's a lot of fun
all right
select the best interpretation of the
following equation so we have the
absolute value of 11 minus X so this is
the distance between 11 and x equals the
absolute value of y minus 3 so this is
the distance between y + 3 so this is
telling us that the distance between 11
and X is the same as the distance
between y + 3 so they say the distance
between 11 and X is equal to the
distance between y + 3 yeah that's
exactly that's exactly what I just said
so I would select that let's look at the
other choices
the distance between 11 and at negative
x is equal to the distance between y and
negative 3 well the distance between let
me let me underline this the distance
between 11 and negative x I mean just in
a different color the distance having
trouble changing colors so the distance
between 11 and negative x that's not
going to be this over here that's going
to be you could take the absolute value
of 11
and then from that you would subtract
negative X that's this that's this thing
right over here so this would actually
simplify to the absolute value of 11
plus X which is not what we have over
here and then the distance between y and
negative 3 same idea that's going to be
y minus negative 3 which is not what we
have over here so this is not this is
not what this would this eat what this
equation represents the distance between
11 and y okay so now they're really
mixing they're saying 11 and Y is equal
to the distance between negative x and
negative 3 so now they've just
completely mixed everything up so that's
not going to be the case let's do one
more of these let's do one more so we
are asked which of the following
expressions is equal to the rectangles
area all right so if we want to figure
out the area of a rectangle just
multiply the width times the height or
you could say the the length times the
height so let's see which of these
represent that so the absolute value of
J minus L so let me get a color here so
J minus L the absolute value of J minus
L so J minus L so J is this x-coordinate
it's going to be negative 6 and L is
this x-coordinate it's going to be it's
going to be positive 6 so the absolute
value of J minus L is going to be it's
going to be R it's going to be the
difference in the horizontal axis on the
or it's going to be the distance on the
other horizontal axis between this point
and that point if we're going or you say
the horizontal distance between those
two points so it would be the length of
this of this line segment so that is the
absolute value of J minus L once again
the x-coordinate here is negative 6 the
x-coordinate here is positive 6 and you
can even figure it out it's going to be
negative 6 minus 6 which would be 12
negative 12 and then you take the
absolute value of that this is going to
be 12 you don't even have to figure that
out here this we just know that the
length of this line is the absolute
value of J
- L so that's that and then they have
the absolute value of M minus Q so the
absolute value the absolute value of M
minus Q so they have M over here that's
the y-coordinate here and Q is the
y-coordinate down here so the absolute
value of M minus Q is going to be the
distance the vertical distance between
these two points which is really just
because this the x value isn't changing
this is actually going to be the length
this is going to be the length of that
side that's going to be the absolute
value of M minus Q so if you multiply
this length times this length you are
going to get the area of the rectangle
so I didn't have to look at the other
choices I would definitely go with this
one
but let's see where the other ones
probably are not aren't correct so this
is the absolute absolute value of J
minus M so here you're taking the
difference of the x coordinate here and
the y coordinate over there so that's
kind of bizarre so this already looks
looks suspicious here you're taking the
absolute value of J minus n absolute
value of J absolute value of J minus n
well they're x coordinates are the same
so this is actually going to be this we
actually know is going to be 0 J is
equal to n they're both equal to
negative 6 that's not going to give you
the length of this line because we have
no change along the along X here all the
changes along Y if we wanted to figure
out the length of this line right over
here we would have to find the the
absolute value of K of the change in our
in our Y coordinates so absolute value
of K minus o would give you the length
of this line and if you wanted the
length of this right over here you'd
want your change in X so that would be
the absolute value of n minus P or you
could say the absolute value of P minus
n but they didn't use those choices so
yeah we feel good about that